So, what are you planning to do for your vacation?
I want to take a trip somewhere,...
...but I haven't decided where yet.
A trip?
That sounds cool!
Where are you thinking about going?
Well, I was thinking about going to Canada.
I've heard it's a really beautiful country.
Yes, it is.
Where else are you thinking of going?
The other place I'd like to go is Mexico.
Mexico is a lot of fun.
The food and culture there is quite different.
I looked at ticket costs...
...and I think it's actually a bit cheaper to go to Mexico.
I believe it.
I think hotels in Canada are a bit expensive.
Well, the travel agent I spoke with...
...said that I could get a good deal on a packaged tour to Mexico that included flights and hotels.
Then why don't you take that option?
I think I will.